(relaxed music)
- [Narrator] For six months of the year,
crystal blue lagoons appear
in what would otherwise
look like your average desert,
making Lençóis Maranhenses
one of Brazil's most
mysterious destinations.
Lençóis Maranhenses is a
national park located in Brazil.
From January to June, the area
becomes inundated with rain storms.
The rain water collects
between the sand dunes,
creating thousands of clear water lagoons.
Some of these pools reach
over 300 feet in length
and can be over 10 feet deep.
With water temperatures
as high as 87 degrees,
visitors come from far and wide
to experience the pristine conditions.
But arriving at these
pools is no easy feat,
and renting a four-wheeler is a must.
The ride is rough, as you
need to cross tight spaces
and navigate through rivers and puddles.
Lençóis Maranhenses visitors
must enjoy these pools
while they can, because come dry season
this spectacular landscape vanishes
and returns to its desert form once again.